I'm a dad I'm a dad I am a dad I'm a dad
I'm a dad I'm a dad I'm a
dad first thing I want to do is look at
the bags under everybody's
eyes okay all right that's pretty maybe
we're just all
tired are these your everybody's only
kids or do people have more only we have
more kids I have a lot so this is one of
six
total oldest uh no he's the second
oldest second oldest how old did you say
you were again I'm 33 the two older are
um from my husband's first marriage okay
so uh we have also a 14-year-old okay
for me I was like six kids that's a lot
to be a step parent so I think that was
one of the thing that I was I wasn't too
sure about you know someone wanting to
be a stepdad for six kids stepdad that's
nice
man he's not the stepdad he's the dad
that stepped
up truly I've got one other I've got a
son he was uh just bornn he's a month
old Dante and then uh her I have two
this is my oldest and then my daughter
she's uh 7 years old so those are the
only two that I have right now I do want
at least three more and I want have five
just keep going we're all going to have
families here let's go for it have to
find how to Happ I got I got one more uh
same thing he's seven and he's the last
one two is enough three months in I feel
like I'm done
too I want to football team
basically I'm curious like what's the
most shocking thing or maybe most
difficult thing about fatherhood cuz
that's something maybe we can all can
relate to I think for me is I didn't
feel like a like a dad it was more like
a school project like I just got to make
sure it's all right the day first I
thought it was him because like he was
kind of tossing the kid around I was
like oh Jesus this got to be like an
uncle type figure the part that's
probably comes the hardest is the
growing up part it seems kind of cheesy
but really like every day she does
something new there was one weekend that
we had a nice little weekend me and my
wife and she was with my parents and she
came back that weekend knowing a few
more words and I was upset that I I
missed that like just those little
moments that you miss like I don't ever
want you to take her again no no no I
don't want her learning anything else at
your
house it's okay what's wrong I think the
hardest thing for me was uh learning how
Not Fragile like kids are cuz like you
always you always hear about like all
the fun stuff that you had to do with
kids and play with them and stuff but
you never nobody ever talks about how
when you hurt them how it's going to
affect you like like the first time you
drop them you're playing a little too
rough but you're tough right yeah you
later I'm always so concerned about this
little girl I'm like dude like everybody
I'm always making sure they're washing
their hands like making sure they're
like oh you didn't pet any dogs did you
oh I can't I was having second thoughts
on Elijah too only because he was
younger than him yeah I have a feeling
that Elijah is also suspicious I think
I'm going to have to Pig it back off
that too like the not just emotional
toll but like the physical toll like
you're not just physically there for
your child like you're emotionally there
for them all the time they become a mini
like this is my mini me essentially
right like everything my values and
everything becomes him right he it
looked like they were like uncle nephew
because they were like playing around a
lot and oh also um that Nathan and Aiden
were wearing matching necklaces
everything is both harder and easier
than I expected it to be so it's like a
lot of like the mechanics of like I have
three under three so like putting them
into the car is like so difficult but
then everyone's like oh how are you like
doing bed times and stuff and it's like
[Music]
I he was just carrying the baby kind of
like sitting down instead of just
putting it to to the side I voted for
Nathan because I just didn't get that
Dad energy from him from somebody who
would have had their kids so young and
gone through all the things that dads do
go through for the first
time surprised because I thought it was
going to be a Liah but they all voted
for us cuz Austin voted Austin's son
voted for us uh for those of you who are
at the birth of your child or for those
of you who were there for part of the
pregnancy uh what was that experience
like for you for her cuz um you know
first first kid you take all those
classes and things we did like hypnosis
classes to help Mom get through it and
when did they and none of it happened
the way that we trained for it it didn't
happen that way and I was getting yelled
at and she was screaming I was just
trying to be nice and quiet and just
whatever you need and she was like I
need you to go away like okay anybody
faint no no faint close I didn't realize
it to they were focused on her I'm so
focused on her and every doctor in the
room was looking at me and I'm like hey
like game time and they're like are you
okay and I'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then I sat down and realized like oh
no I'm not you have to play it off for
yeah because if I'm if I'm going like
it's her time to shine I got to sit back
and do be the supportive dad so I wasn't
there for pregnancies because I was step
parent and Foster but I will say when I
was in the process of like dating a guy
with kids I Google searched like gay
stepdad like looking for
books
oh
do
that b i was front line shout out my
girlfriend she was pushing and it didn't
seem like she was so all the doctors are
like good push good push and I was like
really that's the thing is like
everybody always talks about the yelling
noise like you see it in the movies ah
but the reality is when they're pushing
more
like I was like are you doing anything
good job baby during the pregnancy stage
so I was 19 so I was a sophomore in
college and that was probably the most
difficult part because I was in a
fraternity too and they were all going
out and everybody was doing their thing
and I was so left out is that your dad
yes that's my dad his name is Nathan I
kind of had some beef with Dominic cuz
he was all asking me questions like are
you sure he's your dad I was like yes
I'm sure he's my dad you know your dad's
name that's a good start he's 27 years
old his relationship with uh Aiden seems
more of one of two brothers you just
kind of seeing the way they interact the
way they look at each other tell him why
do we even come here you don't even know
why fully yeah you need to taxes and
stuff what's your earliest memory of
your
dad earliest thing you remember can you
gra I remember
um like him like um trying to make me
laugh but that wouldn't really work with
me I'm funny something was off about him
he just wasn't really communicating with
his daughter give us your best
J oh man you yeah I'm not funny
that pretty funny well you know when a
joke becomes a dad joke right when it
becomes a
parent okay that was a good one all
right how about you what's your favorite
memory dad so I was with my mom a lot
that basically whole entire week I was
able to see my new baby
sister and I finally saw her
excited and we spent most of the time
with you
guys think you can find out who's the
fake D well subscribe to the channel to
find out now let's get back to the
video it was like the body language I
saw the kid Pat Nathan on the back and I
was like oh no we didn't like that just
seemed to me like Aiden answered like
that was really his dad so that made me
question my whole thing and then at the
last minute when we go up to vote I'm
like uh I don't think it's Nathan
anymore so that's why I wrote down
Nikki
if everyone feels confident that you
already caught the mole you can end the
game now but if the majority has doubt
the game will continue please raise your
hand if you want to continue playing the
game continue
playing that's two out of five okay so
we will not continue the game if the
lights turn
green you have voted the mole out and
you win if the lights turn red the liar
is still in the square and you lost
please three two
one yes let's
go on the count of three if the mole can
step forward and reveal himself along
with his partner in crime three two
[Music]
one was us well done good job guys I I
messed up yeah I knew you going to let
me down from the beginning I was like I
was trying so hard but I knew like
27-year-old the 27y old he's just going
to let me down thank you we practiced
for way longer than we want to admit so
been a lot of fun how are you guys
related are you related yeah yeah we're
brothers Brothers got it
he almost got me a taxes though I had my
intuition from the beginning and guess
uh dad brains a thing yeah I felt very
happy no it was exciting held it
together good I would hope that people
see this and just see how many different
kinds of fathers there are that's a lot
of what fatherhood is is trying to
figure things out and every kid is
different and you're a different person
too I think the one thing all dads do
have in common though is undeniable love
for their kids and anybody who has that
is capable of being a dad and is a out
in some
way
wow